favi nel prossimo luoghi fai dire ad un
traduttore bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog
io onestamente ho paura di quel che
cazzo possa succedere ma non importa più
ci provo
bella tutti i ragazzi io sono favi ed
oggi siamo in un nuovo vl oggi nuova
casa è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj e non ci
siamo in un nuovo vl oggi e cosa solito
ragazzi cominciamo con la parte della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da alessia che ha fatto sto dice
madonna è una cosa falsetta tricolori mi
piace un casino anche se c'è solo blu su
tutti ragazzi e fantastic elaborati
grazie alessia per averla fatta da volta
volevo fare anche una cazzo di parlato
perché le fate sempre voi quindi mi
sentivo in dovere di farle quindi la mia
fan alto ragazzi è questa qui che
esprime la sua vena artistica in tutto
il suo insieme che cazzo sto dicendo
ragazzi alla sua offerta comunque a
direi di passare alle news perché devo
dirvi n'è una che non ha notato nessuno
proprio in questi giorni non me l'ha
fatto una tra borgo nessuno è perché
hanno cambiato il muro dietro no perchè
giuro non ho letto nessun commento e che
lo diceva sto scherzando ovviamente mi
saranno arrivati 5 6 mila messaggi che
mi chiedevano che cazzo ho fatto al muro
per i 20 ragazzi vi svelo l'arcano
mistero non siete voi che ci vedete male
ma e private mentre ero a barcellona la
settimana scorsa i miei e visto che non
eri in casa perché quando sono in casa
registro e basta hanno approfittato per
rifarmi il muro perché faceva schifo e
oltre che questo ragazzo ho scoperto che
imprime te con tutte le tutele che mi
avete mandato mi stava praticamente
crollando la mensola infatti adesso
praticamente tolte quasi tutte per il
semplice fatto ragazzi che mentre
verniciava non si sono accorti che la
mensola stava crollando
quindi era possibile che durante il
sonno mi crollasse in testa tutto
ammettetelo che era un piano per tentare
di uccidermi voi lo sapevate
lo sapevate sin dall'inizio previene
interno reso pubblica la data di uscita
di aulas del dlc quello che deve uscire
che io devo fare purtroppo uscirà
ragazzi il 6 maggio quindi il 6 maggio
ufficialmente posso morire e come ultima
cosa ragazzi mi avete chiesto di fare
uno speciale di per pasqua in occasione
di pasqua e per la prima volta ragazzi
voleva dare a voi la possibilità di
scegliere lo speciale quindi ragazzi
scegliete lo speciale di pasqual che
volete che io faccio possibilmente una
roba fattibile non io che vado
nello spazio ok quindi lega datemi
qualche idea poi vedo io di scegliere la
migliore quella che mi sembra più
divertente e cercherò gli parla nello
speciale di pasqua se riuscirò a favore
di ragazzi ho finito con le news che so
che vi tartassano i maroni che a metà
basta quindi lei di passare allo
scarpaccio dei pacchi parchi che ho
deciso di aprire prima che tentino di
uccidermi sono sono tre tratto questo è
quadrato non mai ricevuto un pacco
quadrato
ho paura di vedere ma ti stai fermo un
attimo ora di vedere che cazzo c'è
dentro e comunque anni ha protratto
questa enorme non ci sta neanche
nell'inquadratura fantastico direi di
partire ragazzi dal più piccolo prima
che agenti di suicidarsi nuovamente
quindi ho paura di vedere che cazzo c'è
dentro spero non ci sia un coniglio o
qualcosa del genere
siete cagate no proprio un cazzo
ma che cazzo mi avete inviato
un chewing gum ragazze mi spiegate
l'utilità di una scatola per un chewing
gum
spero che sia un chewing gum che dia dei
superpoteri perché sennò mi sembra
abbastanza assurdo che ne abbiate
inviato gioia che cazzo a fumetti affo
perché appunto sono io che ho toccato ma
si può
[Musica]
vabbè ragazzi lasciato perdere se cagate
rutelli allora io nel caso sarò in fin
di vita un giorno mangerò questo perché
probabilmente ne tipo un fagiolo di
balzani da dei superpoteri di sicuro vi
ringrazio per questo regalo splendido ed
i rei di passare al prossimo pacco che
ha sì è una matita madonna e pochi e la
scritta la matita di scribblenauts hanno
sradicato un albero intero per far
questo ragazzi e te talmente grosso che
ho paura che cancelli le cose veramente
bona romana non ho capito bene che cazzo
è successo ma non importa adulti ragazzi
cioè io ormai rimango estasiato da tutte
le piste regali splendidi sono odio
minchia quest'esordio queste sono le
cuffie più belle che io abbia mai visto
in tutta la mia vita grazie mille devo
andare in giro assolutamente con queste
minchia che filmò va beh la cosa è la
cosa più morbida che abbia mai toccato
in vita mia è uno dei regali più
splendidi cambiamento non è moltissimo
c'è una cosa che prezzo di antistress fi
grazie mille poi abbiamo una custodia
per madonna ma c'è io io ti voglio bene
cazzo sono bellissimi sti cosi la mia
vita è fottutamente completa ragazzi ho
io non mi staccherò mai più da questo
coso che lo dico e come ultimo ragazzi
abbiamo anche questo che non cos'è sta
roba quanto minchia figo questo ragazzo
il pupazzetto dello slow lander man con
con uno zainetto con scritto fa vj dopo
questo dopo questo avete vinto qualsiasi
godano conca ragazzi tra custodie
cuffiette splendere
io non ho parole siete fantastici perché
per ragazzi e bellissimo sto coso perché
non rimbalza neanche c'è tipo si
schianta al suolo violentemente e
bellissimo cazzo devi ringrazio
tantissimo per il partito perché mi
avete inviato due miliardi di cose e
direi che possiamo passare al fa vidi
sponde la prima domanda ragazzi arriva
da marghe che mi chiede il file risponde
che quella è la parte più divertente da
fare nei video a ragazzi la parte
divertente rafa redivido è ovviamente
ovviamente mi sembra ovvio registrarlo
perché
cioè quando registra video mi diverto
quindi la parte più divertente la parte
che mi annoia un po di più e quando
evito il video perché è divertente di
vederlo prodotto un po dato che evitare
ci metto tipo tre o quattro ore dopo un
po mi cadono i maroni quindi in effetti
mi diverto più quando registro che
quando lo dedico ma questo mi sembrava
anche abbastanza ovvio cecilia
pellegrini fa risponde favi come sai da
vecchio va bè ragazzi pronunciare
un'applicazione per vedere se riesco a
farmi diventare più vecchio hanno paura
di quello che possa uscire sono convinto
però vabbè amido fano una foto prima
ragazzi due amici che i ragazzi ma che
cazzo dovrebbe essere questo ammettetelo
che sono più bello il brad pitt insaputa
c'è ma si muove
preghiamo che cazzo hai mai pensato di
farmi del live senza nessuna ritengo
ovviamente like baglio legge allora
avevo pensato di fare no veramente l'ho
già fatto milan live è più avanti forse
ne farò anche qualcun altro non lo so
comunque è possibile che lo rifaccia più
avanti non so dipende bravi risponde se
leggi questo momento le mani mi offro
volontario nell'interrogazione di fisica
ma quanto a cazzo sono offerti
vabbè ragazzine che per oggi è tutto
posso concludere qui sono anche contento
che gli sia piaciuto il colore nella
camera meno quello è niente ragaglia
dire che possono includere qui il video
è come al solito ragazzi se video è
piaciuto il suo documento mi piace anche
a faccia di facebook come nani video
trovate nella descrizione se ne siete
felici di iscrivetevi ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video belle ragazze